tu es cause la halle m'intéresse
beaucoup et elles ont motivé des
décisions une décision en particulier
que que j'ai prise fermement et que je
souhaiterais l'on sait que décision une
décision personnelle qui est celle de ma
démission en tant que référente de la
république en marche
en martinique qu'est ce qui vous a fait
prendre cette décision il ya plusieurs
vous quitter le navire avant qu'il ne
sont en charlot gressier je ne capte
rien je quitte le poste de référent de
la république en marche pour plusieurs
raisons la première chose c'est que vous
avez des anciens usagers anciens visages
qui perdure ce qui est c'est à dire
c'est à dire vous parlez de plus c'est
pas dans mon éducation donner des noms
c'est plutôt une mentalité qui est assez
perturbante ancien visage anciens usages
contrairement à ce qu'avait promis en
fait le président de la république
emmanuel macron celle envie d'en savoir
plus sur l'autre gressier quels types d'
usage alors si vous me donnez pas de nom
mais y'a leur usage le le type d'usagé
en fait ce sont des pratiques qui sont
désormais intolérable vous avez un
décalage profond entre l'entourage du
président de la république et ce qu'est
devenue la république en marche
en outre-mer et je tiens à préciser
d'ailleurs que
malgré tout je crois encore profondément
emmanuel macron en le président de la
république mais il faut pouvoir
distinguer cet homme de ce qui est
devenu la république en marche quand
vous parlez de décalage est ce que vous
faites allusion également notamment au
chlordécone
alors il ya des sujets effectivement qui
m'ont particulièrement choqué en tant
que martiniquaise
des sujets comme cordes et comme sergas
on a des éléments de langage vous savez
et je trouve déjà l'expression très
laide
il ya certaines choses que je ne peux
pas cautionner comme c'est m6 est un
autre thème aussi que je pense très
important puisque vous parlez du
séminaire sur les européennes c'est
cette grande difficulté à pouvoir porter
une candidature comme celle des antilles
françaises
aussi légitimes que n'importe quel hôtel
toile trois marins
au niveau des européennes justement
parce qu'elles ont quelque chose à
apporter et on se retrouve face à une
logique qui est plus électorale et
malheureusement mathématiques qui sera
le guide désormais peut-être un retour
de jacky le courtier je ne sais pas qui
une réponse donc de votre part à la ça
ne me concerne plus il faudra voir avec
paris